will Biden be the nominee so there's
some interesting stuff we've got some
info from valuetainment uh Michelle
Obama rumored to have plans to replace
Joe Biden in the 2024 election a New
York Post columnist alleges that there
are plans underway for Michelle Obama to
enter the 2024 presidential race this
summer as President Joe Biden's approval
rating continues to fall and Donald
Trump continuously outperforms him in
the polls many observers including
prominent members of Congress argue such
a scenario is increasingly likely
additionally a poll from August found
that the majority of Democrats would
prefer Michelle over Joe the writer New
York City based socialite and gossip
columnist Cindy Adams claims sources
have told her that Obama has pulled
donors to gauge the reception of a
campaign Trail intervention apparently
there is a plan to have Biden announce
in May that he is not running and have
the former first lady take the
nomination without a primary vote during
the DNC convention in August in a
different column Adams claims that
Michelle Obama sent a survey to
Democratic leaders asking how they would
feel about her running additionally she
reports that in the summer of 22
Michelle held a meeting in New York City
with major headed fund uh hedge fund
CEOs and told them I am running and I am
asking for your support during an
appearance on Jay shett podcast in early
January Michelle remarked that she is
quote terrified about the 2024 election
uh Sarah that Camala lady can't be happy
about this like how are they going to
push like it does seem obvious to me
that the guy could fall today like while
we're on air it could all end but they
still have to get rid of Camala and uh
that's going to be a real issue yeah I
mean here's the only way that I can see
that playing out easily Optics wise is
if kamla Harris something happens to Joe
Biden uh you know God forbid that he
just heels over and dies but even not
even if not um they could just say you
know what there's some health issues and
he's going to go ahead and step away
kamla has her time in the spotlight for
like 9 months and then she actually just
voluntarily says I've had my time I was
the first woman president and I'm G to
go off and do something else and then
Michelle Obama uh gets past the torch I
now having big mic I'm sorry Michelle um
up there scares the hell out of me um
it's not you catch that mice did you C
did you catch the reference there CAU it
I CAU you got it you got it okay not
something that I want to will into
existence because that's terrifying to
me but it I mean they need to do
something that's the point the Democrats
know they have to do something whether
it's Gavin Nome or Michelle Obama they
know they cannot run this walking potato
for another four
years but they the potato won the
potato's in the office and that in
potato won by hiding the potato won by
hiding years well but but he hasn't hid
for the last three years we've seen him
sure I I mean I know you agree with me
that it's not a given that he's gonna
lose like at all especially if Trump is
no it's not a given but no it's not but
I think that there's so much isn't it
scary though that like the time that we
have left we we all know there are so
many things hanging out there that so
many things could happen that could
change the game well I mean Trump's no
spring chicken either and I made this
you know when you're like 63 250 at that
age you know yeah he looks good but
things can happen all the time and I
don't wish for bad things for almost
anyone other than corporate journalists
but I I think this to the point I think
this whole Michelle Obama thing is a
complete Boomer fantasy
uh they' just have this fixation
Michelle Obama I know where it comes
from the idea that if Biden is
incapacitated that she'd be the plan B
is crazy she's never won any elected
office she has no political resume much
to speak of and the fact that the the
claim that everyone the Democratic party
who has paid their dues would just step
aside for her is nuts if she wanted to
have it she would could have had it in
20120 um so I think this is completely
false if this survey had actually
happened in writing it would have leaked
and it wouldn't have leaked through
Cindy Adams um so I I'm sure she's very
concerned and so on and so forth but by
all accounts she hated her time in
Washington uh I don't know why she want
to put her I mean would you want to run
against President Trump as a mom and
knowing what he's going to say about you
and your kids I mean forget it so and I
don't see how she's going to tell
Hillary and KLA Harris oh just step
aside Michelle got this that that's not
going to happen can I can I add one more
thing to that Dave sure uh she also to
to Michael's point I mean she lives on
Martha's Vineyard like she has they
they've got their Netflix deal like they
30 ACR on the water not worried about
their money right like right um they've
made their money they're they're very
comfortable she's living the elitist
life that I'm sure she always dreamed of
living so I don't know why she would
walk away from that to do it um I still
think that they're trying to prepare
Gavin Nome to uh to take to take charge
there but yeah I don't if you're if I'm
Michelle Obama I don't want to do that
I'd rather just live my you know live my
fancy
life